some of the nurses at Kansas City
Missouri Hospital have their hands full
they're setting a possible record while
taking care of 12 sets of twins count
them that's 24 right paternal twins
Callie and Camden Riley are nestled in
their mother Whitney's arms he's still
on oxygen and they're both on feeding
tubes right now they are one of 12 sets
of twins in the neonatal intensive care
unit at st. Luke's in Kansas City
Missouri the hospital believes it is the
most it's ever had all of them born
prematurely with the youngest babies
arriving this week it's super stressful
having a baby in the NICU photographer
Helen ransom captured the first images
of the babies and their parents for free
something she does because she can
relate I have identical triplet boys
myself and they spent 17 18 and 20 days
in the NICU
Ransome says the road ahead may be
uncertain for the parents but they
should never forget their first time
cradling their children they don't even
look up at me they are fully in the
moment snuggling those babies and how
your triplets doing now they're
fantastic it has been the greatest joy
to watch them grow and become best
friends with each other now ten percent
of babies born in the US last year were
premature and for the past four years
those numbers have been increasing
according to the CDC st. Luke's is
working to make sure all the twins can
be home by their original due date which
means some of the twins will be able to
spend their first Christmas at home the
CBS this morning Saturday I'm Errol
Barnett shocked I wasn't sent to do the
stories you know twins and triplets are
kind of my specialty
yeah I've done so many stories on them
and you joked about something yeah I'm
going to eat that no you can't I thought
it was kind of funny oh they might be
sponsored